small town usa you've heard the phrase
plenty of times before
the terms tossed around by politicians
and writers alike to represent this idea
of suburban bliss
it sounds idyllic you know what i'm
talking about quaint houses surrounded
by white picket fences neighborhoods
full of friendly ned flanders
hello neighborino to the north i sure
like the cut of your gibberish
but reality isn't always out of a
storybook instead of getting
a flanders more often than not we end up
living next to a homer simpson
and we've all suffered through a bad
neighbor before they borrow your
lawnmower and return it broken
their garage their garbage pails are
always lying in your driveway
and sometimes they even launch an icicle
through your window
a funny thing is happening in america
right now
somehow we've ended up living next to
not one but two clark griswolds
our neighbors canada and mexico are
losing their minds and we're stuck in
the middle
[Music]
but instead of clowns and jokers we've
got communists to the left and cannibals
to the right
when did america become the middle seat
of the worst car ride imaginable up
north justin trudeau is looking to turn
the maple leaf on canada's flag into a
communist hammer and sickle which
shouldn't be a surprise since
he's a long time admirer of china
and having totalitarian control over
your people listen
there's a level of
admiration i actually have for china
because their
basic dictatorship is allowing them
to actually turn their economy around on
a dime
well now justin is getting his chance to
play dictator his administration has not
hid their contempt for the protests
going on in ottawa
since late last month truckers have
turned the city into a parking lot for
their big rigs as they demand the return
of their freedom stolen away by trudeau
but instead of talking or sympathizing
with them canada's prime minister has
decided to go after him
trudeau is bullied into action by a
fearful joe biden
who was worried this freedom display
would make its way south of the border
so he convinced justin to turn up the
heat on his own people
federal government
has invoked the emergencies act
to supplement provincial and territorial
capacity
to address the blockades
and occupations the police will be given
more tools to restore order in places
where public assemblies can constitute
illegal and dangerous activities these
tools include strengthening their
ability to impose fines
or imprisonment
sounds a little extreme for dealing with
some truckers who simply turned off
their engines
this act that he just used was created
for events like natural disasters civil
unrest and war
you know real emergencies it had never
been invoked by the canadian government
until now
think about that
nothing during the war on terror or the
pandemic or the blm riots last year
never once did they play the emergencies
act card
but this week it's being used to squash
political opponents
this is a level of crackdown that would
make even xi jinping jealous
and canada isn't just forcing these
truckers out of the capital they're
going after their bank accounts too
watch
we are directing canadian financial
institutions to review their
relationships with anyone involved in
the illegal blockades
and report to the rcmp or csis
as of today
a bank or other financial service
provider
will be able to immediately freeze or
suspend an account
without a court order
is this canada or cuba they can freeze
your money in your bank account if they
think you're supporting civil
disobedience
and you can't say anything about that or
do anything
this is the straight-up soviet soviet
union playbook
i mean no one's wallet's safe at this
point and it's already started reuters
just reported that td bank froze two
personal accounts containing over a
million bucks that was deposited to
support the protesters
so they'll take your hard-earned cash
disperse at how they see fit and then
say you're no better than a terrorist
we are broadening the scope of canada's
anti-money
laundering
and terrorist financing rules
so that they cover crowd funding
platforms
and the payment service providers they
use
so that's what we're stuck dealing with
on one side and it only gets worse when
we turn our attention south to mexico
and a couple of guys who were up to no
good started making trouble in my
neighborhood the border there is turned
into a dumpster fire burning out of
control and biden's policies fanning the
flames cartels cashing in on his
incompetence as they make a fortune
trafficking humans into our country
and flooding our neighborhoods with
drugs and death
just look at arizona where border patrol
apprehended one man smuggling 85
thousand dollars worth of fentanyl into
our country 85 grand worth of poison
sitting in one guy's hand
that's a recipe for catastrophe
fentanyl overdoses have become the
number one cause of death among adults
18 to 45
killing more people than covid car
accidents or even cancer
nearly 80 000 young lives have been
stolen by this drug
just in the last two years
that's enough bodies to fill up the
dallas cowboys stadium
but has joe ever made his way down to
the rio grande to see this carnage
firsthand of course not
maybe he's actually scared of the
cartels they hang bodies of their rivals
off bridges while reports indicate they
even eat the hearts out of their enemies
torn right out of their chest and then
devoured by a drug runner
this is actual cannibalism and our only
defense is an incomplete border wall
that biden refuses to finish
hell i mean we can't even safely get
avocados out of mexico without the
cartel threatening safety inspectors
it's almost too hard to believe that
this is the situation we find ourselves
in
boy miss lemon this is a pretty bad
neighborhood
oh i just got tagged
we have to finish the wall in the south
and build a fresh one in the north if
this keeps up
or we could just liberate the canadians
from their dictatorship
it's not like america hasn't done that
before
there's room for a few more stars on the
flag and we can't have cannibals as
neighbors
it's not a good look
and it's starting to hurt our property
value hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else